okay there's been a lot of controversy
recently over the use of certain
vocabulary words in the political world
of politics partially as a result of the
debasement coming from Donald Trump's
presidency that is sort of what today's
hatred mail deals with but before that
hey treat male what what is hatred mail
this is hatred mail brace yourselves for
the only information that can
successfully penetrate a tin foil hat
right
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom yes so last week I gave
sort of a lengthier than usual
introduction to hate mail this week's
hatred mail not only requires no
introduction it deserves no introduction
unsub do you Chuck go ahead and vote for
Hillary you sellout Chuck Pakman is a
cuck for the hashtag faux progressive
movement Park man probably shaves his
and then wonders why Dems keep losing
how tall is David Pakman anyway this is
what happens on the soy diets in gets
fellatio ingots fellatio in giffany I
have no idea I think it's I I couldn't I
mean it's not for people who are
listening it's it's not ing ot which is
a word right in ingot
it's ing I TS it's very strange now I
did the only most of this requires no
response and really deserves none
requires no introduction nor nor
response but I want to point out one
thing the vegan here
is Pat and he's way taller than me it
seems not to have influenced your height
well at the time I was growing I wasn't
vegan so maybe maybe I are on to
something it does maybe they are but I
don't think he was ever subscribed he
said unsub do you [ __ ] at what point did
this this guy decide to unsubscribe
we've talked about unsubscribe trolls
who every time we say something they
don't like they very loudly pronounce
that they are unsubscribing how many
times have you research that you were
able to unsubscribe ten times right like
what are you unsubscribing Andry
subscribing endlessly it's very weird
only now does he realize that your
CUC and a soy boy and a shill for
hillary i mean come on you could see
that coming years of what years apart I
like a good miso soup but beyond that I
don't really have high soy consumption
in my diet III have a lot of soy you do
I do
yeah you I am he's a bit we could call
you a b12 soy boy yes I think that
that's a that's a fair name okay hey
tree at 40 is a coupon code b12 soy boy
what are we talking about the ring I
embrace it cut all of this out from the
from the edit before we send it out hey
tree at 40 will save you 40% off of your
membership memberships are great because
they not only support us hey tree it's
cry when you when you when you get a
membership